I get asked a lot what the difference between my work is
and typical Pentagon long-range strategic planners.
And the answer I like to offer is
what they typically do is they think about the future of wars
in the context of war.
And what I've spent 15 years doing in this business --
and it's taken me almost 14 to figure it out --
is I think about the future of wars in the context of everything else.
So I tend to specialize on the scene between war and peace.
The material I'm going to show you is one idea from a book
with a lot of ideas.
It's the one that takes me around the world right now
interacting with foreign militaries quite a bit.
The material was generated in two years of work I did
for the Secretary of Defense,
thinking about a new national grand strategy
for the United States.
I'm going to present a problem
and try to give you an answer.
Here's my favorite bonehead concept from the 1990s in the Pentagon:
the theory of anti-access, area-denial asymmetrical strategies.
Why do we call it that?
Because it's got all those A's lined up I guess.
This is gobbledygook for
if the United States fights somebody we're going to be huge.
They're going to be small.
And if they try to fight us in the traditional, straight-up manner
we're going to kick their ass,
which is why people don't try to do that any more.
I met the last Air Force General who had actually
shot down an enemy plane in combat.
He's now a one star General.
That's how distant we are from even meeting an air force
willing to fly against ours.
So that overmatched capability creates problems --
catastrophic successes the White House calls them.
(Laughter)
And we're trying to figure that out,
because it is an amazing capability.
The question is, what's the good you can do with it?
OK?
The theory of anti-access, area-denial asymmetrical strategies --
gobbledygook that we sell to Congress,
because if we just told them we can kick anybody's asses
they wouldn't buy us all the stuff we want.
So we say, area-denial, anti-access asymmetrical strategies
and their eyes glaze over.
(Laughter)
And they say, "Will you build it in my district?"
(Applause)
Here's my parody and it ain't much of one.
Let's talk about a battle space.
I don't know, Taiwan Straits 2025.
Let's talk about an enemy embedded within that battle space.
I don't know, the Million Man Swim.
(Laughter)
The United States has to access that battle space instantaneously.
They throw up anti-access, area-denial asymmetrical strategies.
A banana peel on the tarmac.
(Laughter)
Trojan horses on our computer networks
reveal all our Achilles' heels instantly.
We say, "China, it's yours."
Prometheus approach, largely a geographic definition,
focuses almost exclusively on the start of conflict.
We field the first-half team in a league
that insists on keeping score until the end of the game.
That's the problem.
We can run the score up against anybody,
and then get our asses kicked in the second half --
what they call fourth generation warfare.
Here's the way I like to describe it instead.
There is no battle space the U.S. Military cannot access.
They said we couldn't do Afghanistan. We did it with ease.
They said we couldn't do Iraq.
We did it with 150 combat casualties in six weeks.
We did it so fast we weren't prepared for their collapse.
There is nobody we can't take down.
The question is, what do you do with the power?
So there's no trouble accessing battle spaces.
What we have trouble accessing is the transition space
that must naturally follow,
and creating the peace space that allows us to move on.
Problem is, the Defense Department over here
beats the hell out of you.
The State Department over here says,
"Come on boy, I know you can make it."
And that poor country runs off that ledge,
does that cartoon thing and then drops.
(Laughter)
This is not about overwhelming force, but proportional force.
It's about non-lethal technologies,
because if you fire real ammo into a crowd
of women and children rioting
you're going to lose friends very quickly.
This is not about projecting power, but about staying power,
which is about legitimacy with the locals.
Who do you access in this transition space?
You have to create internal partners. You have to access coalition partners.
We asked the Indians for 17,000 peace keepers.
I know their senior leadership, they wanted to give it to us.
But they said to us, "You know what?
In that transition space you're mostly hat not enough cattle.
We don't think you can pull it off,
we're not going to give you our 17,000 peace keepers for fodder."
We asked the Russians for 40,000.
They said no.
I was in China in August, I said,
"You should have 50,000 peace keepers in Iraq.
It's your oil, not ours."
Which is the truth. It's their oil.
And the Chinese said to me, "Dr. Barnett, you're absolutely right.
In a perfect world we'd have 50,000 there.
But it's not a perfect world,
and your administration isn't getting us any closer."
But we have trouble accessing our outcomes.
We lucked out, frankly, on the selection.
We face different opponents across these three.
And it's time to start admitting
you can't ask the same 19-year-old to do it all, day in and day out.
It's just too damn hard.
We have an unparalleled capacity to wage war.
We don't do the everything else so well.
Frankly, we do it better than anybody and we still suck at it.
We have a brilliant Secretary of War.
We don't have a Secretary of Everything Else.
Because if we did, that guy would be in front of the Senate,
still testifying over Abu Ghraib.
The problem is he doesn't exist.
There is no Secretary of Everything Else.
I think we have an unparalleled capacity to wage war.
I call that the Leviathan Force.
What we need to build is a force for the Everything Else.
I call them the System Administrators.
What I think this really represents
is lack of an A to Z rule set for the world as a whole
for processing politically bankrupt states.
We have one for processing economically bankrupt states.
It's the IMF Sovereign Bankruptcy Plan, OK?
We argue about it every time we use it.
Argentina just went through it, broke a lot of rules.
They got out on the far end, we said, "Fine, don't worry about it."
It's transparent. A certain amount of certainty
gives the sense of a non-zero outcome.
We don't have one for processing politically bankrupt states
that, frankly, everybody wants gone.
Like Saddam, like Mugabe, like Kim Jong-Il --
people who kill in hundreds of thousands or millions.
Like the 250,000 dead so far in Sudan.
What would an A to Z system look like?
I'm going to distinguish between what I call
front half and back half.
And let's call this red line, I don't know, mission accomplished.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
What we have extant right now,
at the beginning of this system, is the U.N. Security Council as a grand jury.
What can they do?
They can indict your ass.
They can debate it. They can write it on a piece of paper.
They can put it in an envelope and mail it to you,
and then say in no uncertain terms, "Please cut that out."
(Laughter)
That gets you about four million dead in Central Africa over the 1990s.
That gets you 250,000 dead in the Sudan in the last 15 months.
Everybody's got to answer their grandchildren some day
what you did about the holocaust in Africa,
and you better have an answer.
We don't have anything to translate that will into action.
What we do have is the U.S.-enabled Leviathan Force that says,
"You want me to take that guy down? I'll take that guy down.
I'll do it on Tuesday. It will cost you 20 billion dollars."
(Laughter)
But here's the deal.
As soon as I can't find anybody else to air out,
I leave the scene immediately.
That's called the Powell Doctrine.
Way downstream we have the International Criminal Court.